Ossipon is food our president is three
years older than I am I believe and my
boss mr. Otto is three weeks older if
they can do it why shouldn't I be able
to as well but the most important thing
is being needed I don't feel like I'm
right for the scrapheap yet I can still
do something and be useful the pensioner
is a full member of the staff again
mid-nineteen meeting the department head
discusses what's to be done this week IT
specialist yokomo hot sick missed the
exchange with his colleagues he had
worked for the auto retail company in
Hamburg for forty five years and had
built up its controlling system then he
retired two years ago his know-how was
suddenly needed again before Geneva
shrine I didn't want to seem like a
know-it-all so I introduced myself to
the young people with my first name I
said I'm Johann and that was what made
them trust me and say this guy's okay
the auto firm has founded a special
company for its retirees they are given
limited term project based contracts
their salaries are like those they had
before retirement if you still feel good
at 67 what speaks against it it's fun I
don't have to I'm allowed to feel fit or
healthy and still enjoy working there
should be possibilities for them to
continue they shouldn't rigidly be
forced to retire at 65 or 67 humans 80
get started and I'd feel
German law stipulated that foundry
technology master Gunther Schmidt
initially had to retire when he turned
65 then auto manufacturer Daimler
brought him back to help with a major
project
today he works as a senior expert
working together with a young colleague
he passes on the knowledge that he
gained during about 50 years of
professional experience if you approach
people and feel a positive resonance and
are respected rather than running around
here like a clown then it's a lot of fun
there are now about 500 pensioners in
Daimler's pool of experts
their contracts are limited to a maximum
of six months I'm 69 years old and I'm
going to continue to work here in
Germany until the end of 2017 and then
I'm going to work full-time in Denmark
in Denmark I'm allowed to work as long
as I'm able to work as a professor many
people who retire early are going to get
bored watching television all day long
especially if you retired and you're
retired for five years maybe it's fun to
be retired for 10 years 15 years 20
years 30 years it's true James waffle is
a demographics expert and heads the Max
Planck Institute in Rostock he's
American by birth he says the German
retirement system is outmoded and it's
claimed to create fairness between the
generations is absurd I don't think it's
fair at all I think it shows a lack of
solidarity it shows a lack of sympathy
for younger people in the United States
is flexible so you're not allowed to
dismiss somebody from his or her job
because of age you only can force
someone to retire if the person is
unable to do the work the person
supposed to do but as long as the person
can do the work the person can keep the
job so in the United States I could work
as long as I wanted to will that be
possible in Germany one day yoga and my
coccyx and good to Schmidt would welcome
it they can imagine continuing to work
for a long time even though they are
both around 70